The answer is 2 times the square root of 13. Great thinking if you found this
number. We want to find the distance between these two points. So, we need to
set up a right triangle with the vertical distance and the horizontal distance.
The horizontal distance between x equals negative 1 and x equals positive 3 is
4. We have to move four units in the x direction to get from x equals negative
1 to x equals positive 3. Now we need to find the vertical distance. We start
at y equals 2, which is here, and then we go all the way up to y equals 8,
which is here. So, this vertical distance on the y axis is a distance of 6
units. Once we've found these two legs of our right triangle, we can use the
Pythagorean theorem to find the hypotenuse. So, we'll have this leg squared,
plus this leg squared, equals d squared, our hypotenuse. We solve this equation
to get d squared equals 52. And then we take the square root of both sides to
get d is equal to the square root of 52. Simplifying the square root of 52,
we'll get d is equal to 2 times root 13. This is our simplified distance. And
again, notice that the horizontal distance is simply the change in the x
values. We went from x equals negative 1 to x equals 3. And notice that the
vertical distance was the change in the y values. We went from y equals 2 all
the way up to y equals 8. So, we'll have the change in y squared, plus the
change in x squared equals d squared. We can use our algebra skills and
eventually solve for d.